قد يبدو ان توفر مياه الشرب امر بديه لكن
ليس بعد الان فمع استمرار ازمه الجفاف
الناجم عن شح الامطار خلال فصل الشتاء في
فرنسا اصبح مستقبل توفر المياه الصالحه
للشرب في السنوات المقبله من التحديات
الكبيره التي تواجهها السلطات الفرنسيه
ازمه الجفاف نتيجه نقص مياه الامطار في
فرنسا بدات تاخذ منحا اكثر خطوره فمستقبل
توفر مياه الشرب في السنوات القادمه بات
على المحك ولداري مخاطر عدم القدره على
تامين الامدادات دعا تقرير حكومي فرنسي
الى تغيير جذريا في الاستهلاك لتجنب كوارث
نقص مياه الشرب في السنوات المقبله سنعاني
في 2050 الى 40% من الاشخاص على سطح الارض
سوف يعانون من ازمه المياه ستكون ايضا
ازمه المياه للاسف هي مصدر النزاعات
والخلافات وهجره مناخيه كبيره داخليه او
خارجيه وبالتالي يتم العمل اليوم في فرنسا
على التوعيه بموضوع المياه خصوصا المياه
الصالحه للشرب يلاحظ الفرنسيون هذا التغير
المناخي بشكل واضح هنا في سوق المزروعات
مثلا يحاول توما البحث عن نباتات تعيش
لمده اطول بعدما خسر ما خسره من نباتات في
حديقه منزله بسبب الجفاف
تعاني النباتات كثيرا في الوقت الحالي
فتغير مناخ الفصول يسبب عواقب وقيمه عليها
ما يجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه من حيث الجفاف
لكن اكثر ما يشغل تفكير زوجته ماري هو خطر
نقص مياه الشرب في المستقبل
40 نحاول توفير اكبر قدر من الماء نستحم
باعتدال ونكون حذرين في سهله وفي تطور اخر
مرتبط بهذا الجفاف اندلع حريق هائل جنوب
فرنسا قضى على نحو 930 هكتارا من الغابات
ليتسبب باضرار كبيره في تلك المنطقه رغم
نجاح السلطات في اخماد النيران زناعه
العربيه باريس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات